- Lionel Hutz is unstoppable,
and the best part is,
if you don't win your
case, your pizza is free.
- You'd be surprised how often that works.
You really would.
- So contrary to popular
belief, Lionel Hutz, A tier.
(light music)
Well, it's finally happening.
Today, we are going to rank
all of the fictional lawyers on TV.
Now, usually when you see
these sort of tier rankings,
they're people's opinions, but
that is not the case today.
These are absolutely
true as a matter of law,
because of course I have
the power of attorney.
The power of attorney!
Though, at the same time, I
have no idea what I'm doing.
If only there were some
sort of YouTube channel
that specialized in tier
rankings that could lend a hand.
- I might be able to help with that.
- Oh, Tier Zoo.
What are you doing here?
Got any tips on how I should rank
all of these fictional TV lawyers?
- Tier lists are best used to
compare characters in games
where each character has
a unique set of abilities
and a lot of variation in their stats.
Attributes like mobility,
raw power and defense
heavily influenced how well
a character can match up
against the rest of the game's roster.
The devs designed the characters
to hopefully be fairly equal in viability,
but the best players will
still naturally gravitate
towards the characters that
have advantages where it counts.
Those characters, called top tiers,
are gonna comprise your A and S tier.
Characters that have a lot of potential,
but maybe have one or
two major weaknesses,
are gonna take up your middle tiers,
as will the sort of Jack
of all trades characters.
And in the bottom tiers,
that's where you'd find the characters
that nobody in their right
mind would play competitively,
usually because they're
hugely lacking in power
or have a massively exploitable
flaw in their strategy.
- Yeah, I'm not sure that
that entirely applies
in this particular
case, but what the heck?
Let's give it a try.
- Sorry man, I don't make the rules.
- Well, thank you for
stopping by, Tier Zoo.
So today we're ranking
fictional TV lawyers
and we'll be doing that
using several criteria.
First of all, law skills.
Self-explanatory, we're ranking lawyers.
Second of all, fighting ability.
This includes, of course,
intelligence, power, defense,
mobility, vitality, and stealth.
And then finally third,
do they have any sort of special ability
that would give them an advantage
in or outside of the courtroom?
All right, with the rules established,
let's get in and rank these lawyers.
Phoenix Wright, a longtime favorite
of viewers of this channel.
Recent law grad, high fighting ability,
seems to have reasonable intelligence,
seems to be reasonably fit.
The problem is his law
skills are extremely,
extremely lacking.
- [Phoenix] Objection!
- Being a new recent law grad,
it seems like there's almost
someone else controlling him,
telling him what to do
because he has absolutely
no idea what he's doing.
He's often told what the evidence is
by witnesses to the case,
has no comprehension of
the rules of evidence,
and is a terrible trial lawyer.
He's even been accused of murder himself.
Though special abilities
do include bike riding
and excellent hair,
though this is not enough
to save Phoenix Wright
from absolute F tier, garbage.
Ace attorney?
More like (beep) attorney.
- Monster.
(video game music)
- Theodore Ted Bucklin
from the TV show "Scrubs",
the in-house lawyer for
the hospital Sacred Heart.
Actually, lawyer skills
were not too too bad,
middle of the pack here.
Often gave reasonably
good advice to the doctors
and administrators of Sacred Heart.
- If you know about something,
by not reporting, it you're
every bit as culpable.
Now is there anything you wanna tell me?
- Unfortunately, no one ever
ever followed Ted's advice.
Known as the hospital sad sack,
you're only as good as your
ability to get your clients
to actually follow your advice,
and Ted was simply
never able to get anyone
to follow any of his advice.
Though special abilities
include flop sweat.
- Ted, you ready to get started?
- Whenever you're ready, Nina.
- His ability to basically
be invisible at all times,
and of course his ability
to sing like an angel.
♪ When you wish upon a star ♪
RIP Sam Lloyd,
and one of my favorite portrayals
of any lawyer on TV ever
not withstanding, D tier.
(video game music)
Bob Loblaw from "Arrested Development".
Bob Loblaw needs no introduction,
especially with respect
to Bob Loblaw's law blog.
- Of course, the Bob Loblaw law blog.
Wow, you sir are a mouthful.
- He can do anything that
Barry Zuckerkorn can do,
plus skew younger.
He gets extremely high materia
from the fact that he's able to bill
out of just about everything.
- Why should you go to jail
for a crime someone else noticed?
- Still, his lawyering skills themselves
are a little bit underwhelming.
C tier.
(video game music)
Maggie Lizer from "Arrested Development".
Known as one of the most feared
attorneys in Orange County,
being able to navigate the
legal waters in Orange County,
despite her apparent blindness.
But of course she wasn't actually blind.
- I submit into evidence this wine glass
with the defendant's fingerprints.
(glass breaking)
- This gambit gave her high stealth,
but very, very poor mobility,
especially given the fact
that her special ability,
her seeing eye dog Justice,
actually happened to be blind.
In this case, no avoiding F tier lawyer.
(video game music)
Eli Stone from the
eponymous TV show on ABC.
I didn't really see this one,
and apparently no one
else saw this either.
Has a good last name.
Lawyering skills were apparently okay,
though his special ability
did include hallucinations,
which is actually a bit of
a nerf in and of itself.
- Are you God?
- Well, someone has said so.
- [Devin] So, I don't know, D tier?
(video game music)
Saul Goodman slash Jimmy McGill
from "Breaking Bad"
and "Better Call Saul".
- Hi, I'm Saul Goodman.
Did you know that you have rights?
- Here, Jimmy slash Saul's
lawyering abilities are top-notch
despite not going to a top law school.
- The University of American Samoa.
Go Land Crabs!
- He is able to dig in when he is willing
to put in the time and the
effort to get the results,
and his knowledge of civil procedure
and just interpersonal relationships
is absolutely top notch.
And later in the game,
Saul gets access to one
of the best partners
in the entire build, Huell.
Though because Jimmy is so
absolutely unscrupulous,
that does knock him down a peg.
So close to getting S tier,
but easily makes A tier.
(video game music)
Barry Zuckerkorn from
"Arrested Development".
Perhaps the worst law
skills of any attorney
on this entire list.
There's a reason why the Bluths
have just the worst (beep) attorneys.
- I got the worst (beep) attorneys.
- And Barry Zuckerkorn is
absolutely no exception here.
- I had a really
interesting date last night,
a woman who actually works two jobs.
- He doesn't read contracts.
He gives terrible, terrible legal advice.
He does have a special ability
and that is dance management,
but because he is more interested
in running a dance studio
than he is actually
practicing law, F tier.
(video game music)
Annalise Keating from "How
To Get Away With Murder".
I covered the show in
a Real Lawyer Reacts.
Honestly, it almost caused me an aneurysm.
- [Keating] I lied.
This isn't a past case,
but when I took last
week after Gina fired...
- Wait, are there law students there?
The show is ridiculous, and
the character Annalise Keating,
I don't think actually knows
anything about the law,
despite the fact that she
is a putative law professor.
But she makes up for her terrible
or non-existent lawyering skills
with a special ability group attack.
She basically just corrals
all of her law students
to fight for her, leading
to the interesting tech
of Group Cyclone.
- This is not an advanced
trial skills class.
In fact, this is not a class at all.
This is a sacrifice.
- Also, let's just say
she has rocket punch.
Absolute D tier trash.
(video game music)
Harvey Specter, and
Mike Ross from "Suits".
These guys are all over the map.
Harvey Specter is known as the
best closer at the law firm.
- I'm not just a lawyer to Jerome, okay?
I'm, I'm more like Robert
Duvall in "The Godfather".
- But he is almost never able
to actually close things.
His actual legal skills in
the courtroom are subpar.
He likes to bluster without
actually knowing when to object,
rarely makes the right objection,
makes speaking objections,
and is just an okay at best trial lawyer.
Mike Ross, on the other
hand, is supposed to be
this God-like attorney.
He has a photographic memory,
but the thing is, a photographic memory
doesn't actually help you as an attorney.
As we saw from some of
the very first episodes,
despite the fact that he
could remember things,
he didn't actually know the
things in the first place
when it came to actually litigating.
- Usually, the trial
starts and there's a judge,
and then people say things.
- You've never done this before, have you?
- He needed help from the paralegals.
He didn't know anything
about legal research,
which is what most lawyers do,
and he isn't great at brief writing.
(Devin sighs)
These guys, ah, B tier.
(video game music)
The Unfrozen Caveman lawyer
from "Saturday Night Live".
Lawyer Key Rock was a caveman.
He was frozen during the ice age
and scientists were able to thaw him out.
As a result, he's a
stranger in a strange land,
and he's confused by
our modern accoutrement.
- Your world frightens and confuses me.
Sometimes the honking
horns of your traffic
make me want to get out of my BMW.
- He uses that to great advantage.
His special ability is,
of course, confusion.
He uses that confusion, or
"confusion", If you will,
to confuse the jury into
basically finding for his clients
in every single trial
he's ever participated in.
Despite his appearance,
extremely high intelligence,
leading to great fighting ability,
though he does have pretty
low vitality as a result of,
you know, frankly, being frozen.
And one of two lawyers on this list
portrayed by Phil Hartman.
Actually, not to spoil anything,
but I'm not sure the character
voiced by Phil Hartman
has ever lost a trial.
But in particular, the
Unfrozen Caveman lawyer
uses his personal history
to the best of effect,
never losing a trial.
S tier for sure.
(video game music)
Bobby Donnell from "The Practice".
Bobby Donnell, played by Dylan McDermott.
Let's say, I don't know, C tier,
mainly on account of the
fact that Dylan McDermott
is not Dermot Mulroney.
(video game music)
Lionel Hutz from "The Simpsons".
Now, this is obviously
everyone's go-to punching bag
in terms of lawyers that
are terrible at their jobs.
His own law firm is called I
Can't Believe It's A Law Firm,
and he doesn't appear to know
anything about the law itself.
- Mr. Simpson, don't you worry.
I watched "Matlock" in a bar last night.
The sound wasn't on, but I
think I got the gist of it.
- But there is an extremely
interesting wrinkle
to Lionel Hutz, and that is,
I don't think Lionel Hutz
has ever lost a case.
He successfully represented
Bart in a copyright suit
regarding Itchy and Scratchy.
He successfully represented
Homer in his case
against the restaurant
for unlimited shrimp,
the most egregious case
of fraudulent advertising
since the Never Ending Story.
And he successfully
represented Homer again
in a case against the devil.
Lionel Hutz is unstoppable.
And the best part is, if
you don't win your case,
your pizza is free.
- You'd be surprised how often that works.
You really would.
- So contrary to popular
belief, Lionel Hutz, A tier.
(video game music)
The entire cast of "Ally McBeal".
Frankly, all of these lawyers
are basically interchangeable.
Reasonable law skills, though
they couldn't help themselves
from just engaging in all kinds
of antics in the courtroom,
sometimes doing things that
would get you disbarred.
- Some even cheat.
- Objection, move to strike!
(cat hisses)
- So yeah, D tier.
(video game music)
Perry Mason from "Perry Mason",
and a whole bunch of other things.
Perry Mason is the oldest
character in the entire build.
None of these other characters
would exist without Perry Mason.
He's the one that created the whole idea
of a TV fictional lawyer.
Perry Mason is also extremely successful.
Lawyer skills are above average, I'd say.
Certainly no one can
dispute his results here.
He almost always is able
to successfully defend his clientele,
though he is, of course,
hampered by the eponymous
Perry Mason moment.
- You didn't kill Thompson.
But you did, Mr. Wells.
- Yes!
Yes I killed Ned Thompson!
I killed him!
I killed him, I killed him, I killed him!
- When you have another
witness on the stand
and through a combination of lawyer skills
and just straight up badgering,
you get them to confess to the crime
that your client is accused of.
Now, anyone can represent
a client who is innocent.
It takes real skill to represent someone
who is clearly not innocent,
and Perry Mason benefits
from always having innocent clients.
So Perry Mason really benefits
from his domino-like
special ability, luck.
He's lucky in the clients
that he represents.
He's lucky in that he's
able to elicit confessions
from basically everyone
except for his clients.
That's not the way these things work.
So despite being the
err TV fictional lawyer,
I'm gonna knock him down a peg, B tier.
(video game music)
Ben Matlock from "Matlock".
"Matlock" basically is just a
continuation of "Perry Mason".
It seems to be "Perry Mason",
except in the south, I guess?
Matlock is ethical,
he's a straight shooter
and he's a hell of an investigator.
Matlock is basically a Clefairy Pokemon
in that he is able to cast
his special ability, charm.
Folksy, folksy, Southern charm.
All in all, I'll give Matlock
one more than Perry Mason,
A tier.
(video game music)
Marshall Eriksen from
"How I Met Your Mother".
Marshall is one of the few lawyers
that we get to see grow up,
that we see him studying in law school,
we see him pass the BAR
and we see him enter the
world of private practice.
Marshall is the main character
in one of the greatest episodes
about being a law student
being courted by the big firms,
where he's wined and dined by John Cho,
eats Kobe lobster, and
then does the walk of shame
after drinking far too much.
- Much of what I do does not make me cry.
- His lawyering skills are top-notch.
He has several special abilities,
including the fact that
he can yell lawyered
when people have been lawyered.
- Kaboom, you've been lawyered.
- And of course, powerful slaps.
- I'll let you slap me in
the face as hard as you can.
- You have my attention.
(slap connects)
- I don't really care
how you met your mother,
but Marshall Erickson is S tier, baby.
(video game music)
Harvey Birdman from "Harvey Bird Man".
Here, Harvey's lawyering
skills are mediocre at best.
- Avenger, my personal digital assistant.
Um, how do you make a T again?
Do you push that and then leave it down?
- He bats about a 500
when it comes to taking things to trial.
Usually the trial gets waylaid
by all the crazy things
that are happening as a result
of the superheroes involved.
But his fighting abilities are top notch.
He's powered by the sun,
he can shoot energy beams from his wrists,
he can create a solar powered shield,
and Harvey Birdman can fly.
He's one of the main
attorneys at Seven and Seven,
the law firm, though it does appear
that he got his law degree
from a correspondence course,
which is never a good sign.
But even that can't take
away his power of attorney.
The power of attorney!
C tier.
(video game music)
Jackie Chiles from "Seinfeld".
Clearly a stand in for Johnny Cochran,
reasonably good lawyering skills.
We covered this in A Real Lawyer Reacts.
The problem is whenever
he represents Kramer,
he always loses and he
couldn't even defend the bunch
from a law that doesn't actually exist.
- Good Samaritan law?
You don't have to help anybody.
That's what this country's all about.
That's deplorable,
unfathomable, improbable.
Hold on.
- As we discussed in that episode,
there really aren't
any Good Samaritan laws
that require you to
affirmatively help out people
who have been injured in a crash.
So the fact that the entire Seinfeld gang
went to jail for over a year
doesn't bode well for Jackie Chiles.
B tier at best.
(video game music)
Gerri Kellman from "Succession".
She is the general counsel
to Waystar Royco, feel it,
and she seems to know where
all of the bodies are buried.
Gerri could very clearly run
the entire Waystar Royco company,
though she will absolutely
never be given that chance.
She gives reasonably good legal advice,
whether it's a proxy war
or whether the entire
United States Congress
wants to come down on the company
as a result of what's going on in cruises.
- This may not be the best situation,
but there are harder jobs and
you get a (beep)load of cake.
- Feel it.
Her special abilities include opportunism
and whatever's going on
between her and Roman.
If you've seen the show, you
know what I'm talking about.
Gerri Kellman is just absolutely the best,
but she's never going to
be given an opportunity
to get to the top, and the
same thing holds true here.
A tier, misses out on on S tier.
(video game music)
Jeff Winger from "Community".
This one's tough because the
entire premise of the show
is that Jeff Winger is
not actually a lawyer,
so it's extremely tempting to
just DQ him from this list.
- Are you a good person being
sued, oppressed or beaten?
I can help, and that's
the Winger guarantee.
- Though if memory serves,
I guess in the last season,
he does actually get his BAR license back,
starts a private practice,
then leaves to become a professor
at Greendale once again.
But the thing is, any time
we actually see Jeff Winger
do something that is lawyer-like,
he tends to be pretty bad at it.
- I discovered at a very early age
that if I talk long enough,
I could make anything right or wrong.
So either I'm God or truth is relative,
and in either case, booyah.
- Sometimes he's able
to convince the group
to do what he wants,
and sometimes they just
simply don't listen to him.
So law skills are lacking.
He doesn't appear to have any
special abilities whatsoever.
D tier at best.
(video game music)
Alan Shore and Denny
Crane from "Boston Legal".
These guys are scumbags.
They are womanizers, they're conniving,
and they are loathsome,
but their closing arguments
are the stuff of legends.
There seems to be no rule
that they won't break
in order to get the right
result for their client.
Look, sometimes you
want the scumbag lawyer.
A tier.
(video game music)
Alicia Florrick, "The Good Wife".
Alicia here is able to do a great job
in navigating the
politics of law firm life,
which is not something that
you see all that often,
and she does a reasonably good
job in the courtroom as well.
A little shaky at the start,
but eventually rises to the level
of equity partner in her firm.
So this was a close call,
but I'm going with B tier.
(video game music)
Jack McCoy from "Law and Order".
Here, Jack McCoy's lawyering skills
are absolutely unparalleled.
Perhaps one of the most realistic,
but also just his pure
skill is unparalleled.
Given that his personal code
is that if there is a law out
there, he will enforce it,
he tends to skew towards lawful neutral.
- Where there's a law, I'll enforce it.
Where there's a crime, I'll prosecute it.
And where there's a victim,
I'll speak for that victim.
That's my bottom line.
- He's not about to use the legal system
for his own personal gain,
which leads him to being a civil servant,
a conduit through which
the law is administered
to the rest of society,
and through his hard work and dedication,
he eventually rises to the ranks
of actual district attorney for Manhattan.
Special abilities
include enormous eyebrows
and a motorcycle, so,
you know, there's that.
Jack McCoy easily makes S tier,
one of the best lawyers
in the entire build.
Hands-down S tier, easy.
(video game music)
Now this video isn't over.
Originally, I went into detail
and ranked all of the district attorneys
from every "Law and Order" show,
but the video was just too long and wonky.
She's relentless,
surviving an assassination attempt
by a Colombian drug dealer,
you know, as one does.
But lucky for you, you can
watch the fully extended version
over on Nebula, which you can
now get with a huge discount
when you get it with today's
sponsor, Curiosity Stream.
Because sometimes going into detail
about every district attorney
that "Law and Order" has ever had
doesn't really work on YouTube,
which is why my creator
friends and I teamed up
to build our own platform where
creators don't have to worry
about demonetization or
the dreaded algorithm.
It's called Nebula, and we are thrilled
to be partnering with Curiosity Stream
because not only are our Nebula versions
ad-free and extended, but
they're also released early
before the YouTube versions,
because Nebula is a place
where we can experiment with content
and put things out that we
probably couldn't put on YouTube.
And it features lots
of the top educationalist
creators out there,
like MKBHD, Mary Spender, and hbomberguy.
And we're thrilled to be
partnering with Curiosity Stream
because they're the go-to source
for the best documentaries
and long form educational
content on the internet.
They even have an entire section
devoted to unsolved mysteries and crime.
So if you like my videos,
you'll love the stuff on Curiosity Stream.
And we worked out a deal
where if you sign up for Curiosity Stream
with the link in the description,
you'll also get a Nebula
subscription for free.
And to be clear, that Nebula
subscription is not a trial.
It's free for as long as you're
a Curiosity Stream member.
And right now, Curiosity
Stream is offering 26% off
their annual plans.
That's less than $15 for the entire year
for both Curiosity Stream and Nebula.
So if you click on the link below,
you'll get access to both
Curiosity Stream and Nebula
for 26% off, or you can go to
curiositystream.com/legaleagle.
It's a great way to support this channel
and educational content
directly for under $15 per year.
So just click on the link below.
Plus clicking on that link
really helps out this channel.
And check out the last
collaboration I did with Tier Zoo,
Because if you don't click on my video,
I'll see you in court.